Turkey's president recep tayyip erdogan
says that he will be sending troops to
Libya after a request from the
internationally recognized government
Turkey says it wants to support the
Tripoli based administration which has
been under a months-long defensive by
forces loyal to the warlord Khalifa
Haftar president Erdogan also says that
he'll present a bill on the deployment
to Parliament when it reconvenes in
January from the beginning we have
objected to the coup perpetrated by the
retired general against the lawful
government we provided and are still
providing assistance to Libya's
legitimate government against the coup
plotter who is receiving support from
certain European states Libya is a
neighboring country as we share maritime
border lines in the Mediterranean Sea
once the Parliament comes into session
we will present the proposal for
dispatching Turkish troops to Libya
based on the security cooperation
agreement once endorsed by the
Parliament we will be able to
effectively back the legitimate
government some states who support the
coup general with their jet fighters
tanks and militia object to this move
and criticized Turkey because of it
Mohammed the wired they're standing by
for us in the Libyan capital Tripoli but
first let's speak to Mohammed a dhow in
Antakya in Turkey and what President
Erdogan once President Erdogan normally
gets but he does need to go through the
procedure and he needs his decision
ratified by Parliament just talk us
through the process before those troops
can be sent
one year Sahel he seems to have set his
mind on deploying troops to Libya and
he's already made some progress in that
sense getting approval last week in
Parliament for the military cooperation
agreement between Libya and Turkey and
now it has to go back to Parliament of
course this will happen only when they
get a formal request from the government
in Tripoli for the deployment of troops
and then Parliament will have to take a
vote
and not just take a vote but also map
out the mandate of the troops exactly
what they will be doing in Libya and
what their the parameters for operation
would be so it's said to be more or less
a formal matter it's going to be
presented in Parliament and it's
expected to sail through so it looks as
if Turkey will after all after that vote
deploy troops to Libya and that is
angering a lot of countries particularly
agree especially at a time of rising
tensions over energy deposits in the
eastern Mediterranean Sea and it will
cause follow events from attacking of
course the capital Ankara soir Mohammad
Atta let's cross over the Mediterranean
to Muhammad Abdul Wahid is actually in
Tripoli and of course sir this news will
be encouraging for Prime Minister al
suraj mahmoud he obviously is finding it
difficult to hold on to territory but
how will sort of Turkish troops help
when they do come because obviously as
Mohammed O'Doul said the parameters
around their operation and their
deployment will be very important well
definitely it's very important because
it will most probably make a change on
the ground in terms of defending the
capital tripoli against the military
offensive by a half tons forces remember
Sohail that we spoke to many military
commanders with the GNA the government
of national Accord they
say that after sources have been
recently advancing on the ground taken
control of a strategic locations in
southern Tripoli including military
camps and yesterday they took control of
the the police academy in southern
Tripoli and they have had proceeded
towards the migration Authority compound
and that's near sera Hadean neighborhood
which is very strategic because of the
take control of salahuddin neighborhood
then they can very easily proceed to
this the capital city center that there
are concerns with the military commander
on the ground are very much concerned
about the Russian assistance to have
those forces you know so high that
Russian mercenaries belonging to the
Vagner company have been leading there
after his forces battles to take control
of these strategic locations in southern
Tripoli but as you know that the turkey
wants an official request from the
government of national Accord which is
the legitimate body in Libya as you know
that the military and security
cooperation agreement or memorandum of
understanding that was signed between
Turkey and Libya the last month does not
entail sending troops that is why
president Erdogan is asking for an
official request from the GNA the
government of national code before he
can proceed and set this on top of the
Parliament to be endorsed by the
Parliament in Turkey but in all cases we
know that there have been Turkish
advanced weapons on the front lines here
in in Libya by virtue of the military
agreement that was signed to the last
month but concerning sending troops an
official request from the government of
national code is a must and Turkish
troops on the ground in Libya can
definitely make a change on the ground
so hey well indeed which will continue
to monitor events both in Tripoli and
from Ankara for the moment mahmoud thank
you